yeah I hope I'm life yeah the usual
thing I don't know if I can trust the
software but it tells me that I'm live
here for the twitch stream yeah please
give me a brief info if I'm really life
it would be quite nice to to get I
cannot check myself that would totally
screw up my my screen estate yep thanks
thanks for telling me I'm life I'm going
to start right away with a five minute
game and I'm going to play a little bit
more conservative conservatively
compared to last week simply due to one
fact i have a new mouse and they have to
adjust to this thing it's not so easy i
tried one or two games but it's not so
easy to adjust to it and i think i'm
making progress with with the new it
with the new device but it still feels a
bit awkward it's a good mouse but it's
still you have to get get used to it
okay i don't get a game what is this i
can try for a three minute game now i
get a three minute game okay let's go
three minute yeah I would didn't want to
wait any longer meshach dl yeah that's a
regular opponent let's play Bishop f4
them yeah may the fourth be with you
yeah I realid yet today is the the the
star wars star wars day yeah really
really nice i never knew that me fourth
is the star wars day it makes some sense
yeah but never knew that by the way did
you guys see the star wars trailer for
The Force awakens with the Harrison Ford
and and Chewbacca did you did you see
that I really enjoyed that it was much
fun to see
okay so this is something that I feel I
had on the board before jam like it's
really okay there despite as porn loss
sorry time loss with Bishop back and so
on but the main thing is this is three
minutes yes I have to be quick okay and
my mouse will not not help much in that
I hope I'm really okay there yeah I
Chewie we're home I really like that
yeah it make it if you if you saw the
original movies right as a kid and in my
case it really was as a kid it kind of
feels like you're you're young again yet
see the old Harrison thought they're
talking talking with chewy it's quite
fun okay yeah maybe I will do some some
more um some more um some sharper
openings later I have to adjust a little
bit a little bit to them to the mouse
I'm really sorry about that but I needed
to get a new one my my old mausam really
acted up I had huge problems especially
when it came to UM came to making
painting the arrows and things that was
really awkward and for lessons okay I
can go here Roxy 3 i've got rookie head
yeah Star Wars him well those I don't
know you guys did you did you see them
did you see them the the prequel movies
I only saw the verse the first one the
what was this number episode 1 i've
forgot the the title that the precise
toddler i really hated it yeah that was
really an awful awful stinker of a movie
and I pretty much gave up on those
things then I didn't watch the once
after that it was I know what was this
revenge of the sith and whatever i
didn't didn't bother with that I thought
they were better but I heard that they
were better but I never never watched
them by the way I don't have a clear
plan in this position is this apparent
night c forum Chim i don't want to take
really it's not yeah it's not so easy
for him as well but what is he doing
queen of six maybe chill night a form a
night a form it's not really helping
I have no clear way here to to plain
mighty for route 88 probably hmm Jem I
don't have a clear plan at all and he
has rook a one possibly Phantom Menace
that was the first one right and that
was really terrible with jar jar binks
and wow that was terrible yeah always
found the casting of the movies a bit
off so he's got look coming to turn to a
one can I do can i play that one I'm not
sure about this kind of struggling in
this game I don't don't never saw a good
good way to play for me here I came he's
taking them ok Nabi 5v5 he just has c5
maybe I can somehow get to the b7 pawn I
don't see how but maybe I can assure ya
let's let's get the bishop here so that
it can protect those pawns that's
certainly useful yep to hear look 220 km
up to two I can't play Bishop to a six
maybe now we can always take and Bishop
Fife that's not helping I spin bit slow
here
mmm it's still drawing i know i'm taking
the pawn there hmm ok yeah ok this is
going to be a time win but I'm also
winning on the board now ok um yeah did
you what did I watch the fur off short
exhibition yeah yeah I I did it was very
enjoyable seeing those those to play
it's kind of a bit similar to be honest
I know it it's kind of a weird thing but
it's kind of similar to see seeing han
Solo and Chewbacca in the Millennium
Falcon it's a kind of being young again
that's quite quite fun yeah and it was
enjoyable chess it's a question how do I
approach tournament game by your
opponent is significantly lower rated so
that the draw isn't an acceptable result
those still very solid it's lower rated
but solid yeah how to an how to beat a
weaker opponent yeah it's not so easy
actually I think a good recipe is you
should try to play To Your Strengths no
matter what the opponent opponents
rating it's like it's a very important
not to think that well ok the guy is
weaker than I am so I should do
something that is somehow different to
what you usually do it's a very good
idea to just play what you are able to
do like yeah if you are more of a
strategic player you should still go for
this kind of chess and not try to I know
out with him in some kind of technical
better that you don't understand
yourself it's important to play
according to your strengths and what I
shouldn't do is I shouldn't give up the
night damn Wow see if I it looks ugly ok
let's do it
and whose hands hurt yeah probably in
this equation Nigel short would be Han
Solo and gary is Chewbacca because Gary
is definitely area again probably that
wasn't a great idea of this comparison
but yeah I think you get the point I
mean watching the some heroes of your
youth players always am always fun and I
really enjoyed both both players and
when I was starting starting bus chest
okay this is not a good position yet at
all I'm just worse can I go b6 hope hope
that he plays d5 that's a very very sick
hope I still worse after d5 but
especially amber us if he does not play
it ok can I go if I go back he plays d5
hmm what a bad position
now that looks bad we should be seven
but yeah I got to a new five-minute
record I did and wood will be on on my
channel in a couple of days to 490 is
pretty high high for my for my level
okay here actually went d5 which does
make some sense because my bishop on b7
is so terribly misplaced but I get to
trade some stuff which is definitely
helpful I'm still much worse but I
thought it could have been even worse
yeah probably probably yeah someone is
mentioning that I had this opening
before and I made the same mistake again
that's very much possible yeah Nigel
Nigel said that he was suffering from
jetlag um yeah it always some it always
seems like gasps like a lame excuse yeah
and I the sing this thing that yeah you
that you never have won against an
healthy opponent um this is this joke
there's some truth to that but I what I
do understand is that I mean understand
that Nigel had had problems there with
his sleep and to be honest I have
problems myself with sleeping when I'm
having an important game coming up and
this is a think maybe a comparable
situation to jet lag when you have have
if you had had too little or not not
enough sleep and in such a situation you
just play nonsense it's just what i did
my personal experience if i'm not very
well they haven't slept while I'm
playing badly at least worse then then
what I can do and therefore I have some
some sympathy for what he said so I
don't think it's just the lame excuse um
okay I mean he probably wouldn't would
have lost the match also if he would
been more more and yeah in a better
physical condition is what I'm trying to
say but it's certainly the case that you
would have played better than what you
did because frankly speaking he played
really badly I mean this is something i
don't think that this is anywhere near
what he can do he is still a very strong
GM and in that match he really was
totally destroyed which shouldn't
shouldn't happen really even against an
in-shape Kasparov okay so he allows me
to play you for I'm not sure if I should
do it but let's do that I'm already
satisfied with this this this was much
worse earlier i'm still in some issues
maybe but it was much worse before the d
porn is not going to get away maybe here
yeah can I go g4 and take this hmm I
wonder g4 and take on age five that's a
bit bit materialistic maybe yeah someone
said as a gentleman you don't make
excuses um care to be honest well he was
asked in the postgame interviews Nigel
you didn't play well what is it why
didn't you play well what I is supposed
to say are you going to lie hmm I don't
know it's um I think it's okay what is
this I'm just taking this right I don't
get that I'm just uh just stuff up now
um but how do I win actually may be here
so that I can take with a night and
block the deep on now night to d6 looks
quite good but can I go maybe here right
how do I win this f6 and then 96 that's
also pretty good yeah that's very safe
just F 696 can do this
yeah it's just a piece down for zip and
dip yeah someone is mentioning them the
boxing match with Floyd Mayweather and
I'm not sure how this the Philippine Yin
I'm the guy from the Philippines how is
really pronounced um park we oh I really
i didn't watch anything of it so I
another even had the chance to hear
someone pronounce the name so on so I
don't really know how to pronounce their
this is this person yeah I didn't see
the the boxing the match I didn't see
that one I am I enjoy watching boxing
but don't watch that much what is he
doing Queen somewhere I want to go 95 f
3 and made him as usual being pretty
Paquiao [ __ ] oh ok oh now he resigned
here my opponent which pushes me back on
2500 pac-man yeah they they had this um
Oh Snuka is at 15 15 yeah thats it's fun
I'm not sure that we have worked the
whole day I didn't manage what I really
like snooker a lot it's um it's really
enjoyable to watch yeah boxing is always
interesting especially if you have the
post styles and I heard that Mayweather
was pretty yeah waiting for for for
counter punches and Papac parqueo was
more aggressive yeah you people tend to
be more in favor of the aggressive guy
but at the end i mean the them it counts
and how many hits you you you make so
i'm not i'm not sure i really didn't see
it so i have no clear opinion about this
particular fight but a defensive style
and boxing can be also pretty good okay
yeah we have a strong chance league in
Germany but not so many top players
that's definitely true not quite sure I
mean the the strong Chesney come on
leaks in general um it's probably also
due to the fact that there are some a
fair amount of sponsorship going on so
it's certainly one reason okay that's
interesting he took with the sea pawn
here and opened up opened up his bishop
hmm interesting okay I'm just developing
yeah do I go if I've now on not
interesting okay let's do that that's
very direct for Queenie 495 Queen a
4-hour wait I can actually take on d5
because after Bishop takes this rook a
six that's quite important so he might
not even go to d5 okay yeah and I
definitely intend to intend to keep all
the videos on even if I retire someday
doing videos I don't really plan to do
that to retire because I really enjoy
doing the videos and they're also a good
yeah that's a good platform forum for
showing that I can actually do do do
commentary on chairs and so on it's
quite quite nice and so and yeah someone
mentioned our canteen I'd urge um that
he is switching Federation's yeah I
heard that but i don't really know who
is switching to what federation he is
switching to can someone a level
right on that I really don't know is
he's switching to what does he's
switching to I don't I didn't I didn't
really get ways what he's switching to
yeah someone mentioned that Pacquiao was
I had had more sympathies because yeah
Mayweather seems kind of a well not the
most friendly person I know how to how
to how to call it yeah I really don't
know the guy from the Philippines but
Mayweather seems like um problematic
person let's say nothing from what I
would I heard yeah heaven to when he had
some kind of he had to he did the jail
time I think for for beating his wife or
something which is kind of really really
low on the scale of things to do um okay
what what about this game I have a nice
night there on c5 but he also has
activity Bishop and night I active
tricky position he has in bed night on
c7 but it might come to d5
yeah that's it that's a question about
the world blitz and rapid championships
that it is on the same day or that it is
colliding with the millionaire chest
yeah this is not a very good scheduling
but I'd like to add that this is not
only on the date of the millionaire
chess but also on on on a date where the
German Bundesliga has played so German
first leak and second league which
includes my own my own airplay yeah it's
also during this tournament so this is a
totally ridiculous scheduling which
isn't I think the Bundesliga thing is
actually I'm sorry more important than
millionaire chest because the Bundesliga
is played right in Germany and if we do
the if we have the world rapidin blitz
there the players who play Bundesliga
should be able to participate we are not
talking about German players here but
also german place but we are also
talking about basically a players all
over Europe because the Bundesliga has
has tons of foreign players yeah from
from from Eastern European countries to
France to Spain so it's a it's
completely ridiculous to do it on the
same day then when there's a Bundesliga
weekend so I really don't get that at
all but maybe I'm this is something that
will be will be will be fixed um yeah
maybe they will do some rescheduling
with the with Bundesliga I don't know
but it's it's kind of weird to UM to to
schedule it like that in the first place
ok what is this I was thinking that I
should have something because I might be
near his king someday but he also has
this night a for business so not sure
about it
yeah Adam the Bundesliga has sense many
many players on on on paper that don't
play or very rarely play michiana is
playing sometimes some years ago we also
had magnus carlsen playing but it's
nothing very regular but it's simply
that if we have a Bundesliga weekend um
it is really there's so many many
players that that would miss out on this
event this is totally ridiculous the the
sheer amount of players so I really
don't understand the reasoning behind
this scheduling ok queen d 6 I don't
think I mean maybe he can go look at
three and night f4 but I don't want to
think too long him night f form he might
go out there yeah Luke c7 was my idea
but I'm not sure it's really really
tricky queen is several as rookie 7 and
so I look f7 that's what I was trying to
say take twice now that's not helping
hmm I'm not sure what is he threatening
actually the check there and then rook
f3 maybe
I had to make a move there Wow Queenie 5
is certainly not great but I simply had
to move oh I didn't see that one coming
I can check on a tree night after when
winds are we didn't do that okay it
probably still can win somehow g 3 night
a 2 3 hmm that's not good cannot move
the night ah what a shame don't have any
move them they have to play that it
loses but I have to play it night f to
hook F to look f 2 is that some kind of
way to continue now go here and maybe I
can go here Queen a tree look g 1 a king
g one at least that continues for a
moment ok mmm let's take and I can check
him
wow what a swinger what is swindle you
just ran into a maid that was totally
coincidental boomer Wow okay got some
got some some questions um I got some
gray area I know I know it was it was
just total luck total luck um yeah so
there were some questions my favorite
chess player of all time still alive and
active wow that's difficult that's
difficult um I don't have all time
favorite players i really don't when I
started out I really liked vicious games
a lot because of clarity we had a very
clear style so like carp awful lot when
I started I wasn't so much a fan of
kasparov I don't really know why
nowadays I totally loved his playing
style I mean it's it's very active and
so on it's just great so um there are so
many out of history I really am I really
am like Rubinstein quite a bit it's one
of my favorite players and of the active
modern players I don't have a very clear
preference I really liked Aronian some
play a lot when he was um playing more
successfully at the moment it's kind of
kind of weird to see him play like that
it's not it's not in his best shape um
okay um what do we have here in terms of
questions yeah I'm glad you enjoyed my
reaction to the win it was really fun
okay um let's get a new game going I can
also try okay let's do three minute
reviso thats Grand Master Kuro till yeah
I think koro to laugh he's a 2600 guy
yes Rubinstein was the best player in
the world in right before world war one
that
pretty clear not sure if he would have
won a match against laska but it would
have been a great match to see so let's
see this guy is playing classical stuff
here against the spoke kind of setup
that I'm playing it's not a type of
opening that I know very much very well
but let's let's see what's what's my
opinion on tau ya do you stay an opinion
to have on Todd he was great of course
tar was a really great player one of the
all-time greats he had fantastic games
really and I actually don't agree very
much with people I mean they're
sometimes the opinion that tower was
sacrificing incorrectly a lot yeah and
I'm not really sure about that he wasn't
like he was sacrificing quite a bit yeah
in his games and it was sometimes a bit
a bit iffy but in most cases he was just
playing correctly he was playing
aggressively and it's often his games
have a pretty pretty modern feel to it I
think I mean the opponent's sometimes
defended terribly but he played in a
very enterprising modern style in my in
my book so I really don't see anything
weird with with this play or sometimes
people say he was just like swindling
other guys that's not true absolutely
not I mean in many cases he had he had
games where he at least had him he at
least had like him petrodes or something
like that so it's um it's really not the
case that he was a swindler or something
um he won his fair share of four
positions that were not great but it's
not like he played the play done with
with with totally uncalculated risk or
something okay I'm trying to get the
Queen's of the bottom and their position
is not great but I hope that it's still
kind of playable yeah the queen is and
whenever I do this he would probably
give the Queen hmm I'm not sure they're
i'm not sure if they're if they're what
this is after the Queen after the queen
is Sam is is traded yeah not sure yeah I
think he had to do it but this is not an
entirely clear situation the Rope
doesn't yeah I push this back and now i
can take f2 i have pretty decent
activity here I wonder let's keep this
pawn I don't know he has to look at F 2
and h 2 here and mine my nights I kind
of harmoniously plays maybe h4 how do i
my can i get the night night to e6 to d4
would be good
let's put the knight on d4 and go from
them looks nice my opponent is very high
rated here at 25 30 s is really is
really high in the three minute okay if
I take now he plays look everyone I
don't want that when the night in the
game and now activate the Queen damn
that looks good um okay 97 to 25 maybe
you want Quinn back here okay now i can
i can take a look f1 again c5c okay
tough very tough tough position don't
think I'm in bad shape it's just very
difficult to play okay he wants to go
look everyone again okay cover everyone
looks a bit strange but I don't see add
this move okay this move didn't think
about that one if i go here Knight b6
maybe takes I can take that oh I get up
70 we can take except I totally
overlooked that one okay
yeah I probably meet at him somehow rook
takes a 74 rugby so why am i drawing
with Queen deform now I'm losing on time
I probably lost anyway this was probably
good for black at some point but quite
tricky um okay so there were a couple of
couple of things here mentioned do I
think that Arnold is still a top five
player in the world well obviously his
number two in the current rating list
and yeah so he's clearly top five I mean
the thing is the question which
classical player do you suggest to study
to improve and dynamism forcing play
from nineteen thirty to sixty that's an
interesting error yeah 1930 would
include um ello coin and I would say
that this is this is kind of clear Alec
kind was a great great dynamic player
really and let me do one thing I want to
check who this is Z integrator doesn't
have a name in there very high rated
yeah elocon definitely um um what poo
else in this era Karis was excellent in
positions where it was mostly about
peace play he was really talented with
with peace play okay I'm going to play
aggressively here that is a dangerous
set up white can I can I go H five-year
age 5 h form mmm night back to age seven
this is something who I wonder queen bee
three as a possible move
okay start with that mm yeah that's a
question about cheating how long should
cheetahs be bent difficult to say um
very quickly get people demanding those
lifetime bans and so on yeah well the
thing is that even in other sports where
where where where there's doping people
don't get bent for life quickly you
really have to do many many things to
get a lifetime ban so I'm probably a
couple of years is the right the right
way to do it well there are many
comments and questions it's some
difficult yeah there's a there's a
remark kappa Blanca was more of an end
game player or not um Kappa Blanca also
had his attacking games but he was more
of a strategically focused player which
is also a little bit due to the fact
that he was um yeah he wasn't so keen on
studying opening theory it's simply like
that he was trying to get get games
going and this sometimes meant that he
didn't go to for sharp positions that
often okay what i'm doing here is trying
to be very sharp with age five edge for
i hope this is working could blow blow
up in my face quite a bit yeah i was
thinking h4 h4 and then take on g3 if he
takes it pawn takes Bishop f7 is hitting
so just castling long or h4 still
hmm tricky maybe I have to play a move
like that he might take g54 look at
seven I've 97 now okay let's do that h3
i will take not sure if it's enough but
i will take it looks good for white
probably this whole pollution
yeah annotating annotated games a good
forum for looking at at classical games
and improve your understanding of middle
games if you want a good starting point
for classical games it's really not a
bad idea to start with the power of
books the my great predecessors series
it's a really good overview of chess
history okay let's think about this
takes takes Knight h2 at the end the
problem is that my light squares are so
weak I really don't have any great
continuation there ok it's not
threatening to take at the moment ok
let's do this I mean he's not taking
obviously but this is of course also
putting my king into this into this
Bishop e6 sqm tricky and of course my
own King position is tricky if he takes
H takes G check I'm going to kill him on
the edge file but he definitely won't
take I mean this is kind of clear yeah
this was to be expected what now I'm
just going here he still cannot easily
grab with the pawn and I need to get out
of this yeah I needed to get out of
Bishop e6 maybe as I have ideas here if
I take now there is this leading
anywhere not sure take sticks this
Bishop he is really nice h/t are taking
us not leading anywhere it really isn't
maybe I still have to I really don't see
what else we should be to maybe age for
its not leading anywhere okay i will
take it's not enough but i will take
probably probably this wasn't really
working my planner the that's fun that
my opinion on the bottom hippopotamus
set up for black yet against them some
again some white set up zipper thomas is
quite okay especially if why cannot you
see an F pawn in I mean it's nothing
that i would recommend very much but
it's not terribly bad there are
certainly worse openings around what
kind of a player was smooth slow yes
Mislav was some is very much known for
his son yeah harmony was Miss lost
trademark and kind of fitting given that
he was also mizzou Wow a musician I mean
he was a singer so harmony makes some
sense look at night everyone is a
surprising move rook f8 now it looks
kind of awkward if he has to take I will
have an attack yeah g4 that was clear I
have to do that what is he doing now
look at five maybe I don't know if he
takes all this this looks dangerous why
is he playing Bishop f5 simply maybe
and okay h4 Bishop g4 hmm
I'm h4 Bishop g4 f1 look f1 is not
working what a shame what a shame okay
yeah Queen em okay let's take and push
my own back rank is a week unfortunately
this is one problem Queenie seven or
something like that might be tricky but
okay he has to solve some problems now
okay takes look f5 I cannot play
unfortunately ah what a shame
mmm he really defended as well Queen
edge forms I'm just lost okay it's not
playing that and I played as well a
queen age for analysis ending the game
it's not doing this again okay yeah okay
that was nice I was nicely played yeah
he refuted my attack but be nice okay so
let's have a look there um yeah I
capital like I could attack of course if
he if he was yeah if he had his head the
position to attack he would he would do
that okay let's see what I can do here
this is a lunatic ex let some boom
awesome michalak as an e4 e5 player
would lie would you recommend against an
older man who always wants to play
exchange Spanish I want some sharp stuff
to happen okay okay um yeah some some
sharp stuff to happen against the
exchange yeah if you want something on
move from three I mean it depends a
little bit on the opponent if you feel
that you um okay with somewhat
unconventional positions it might be an
idea to to play em to play knigu seven
the cozy oh that's interesting if you
are if you want an idea in the exchange
itself then it's not it's not so easy I
would recommend to look at maybe a five
Bishop e7 or maybe Queen f6 those kind
of lines are quite quite okay okay let's
see yeah 3 f5 is of course possibly if
you just want want to play in a sharp
way the the Schliemann pin or yanush
a gambit is certainly on the agenda I
don't think that in the game in the
earlier game Bishop f2 was was leading
somewhere I didn't see at least ok he
I'm just trying to try to gain space on
the queenside in this stone wall
formation that definitely I've made some
progress there of course he got this
Bishop to age 5 this is nice for him um
ok i'm not sure if he can play if i if
I'm not do i want to take on play b6
rather not sure about that nightly 2nite
f also might be an idea here not sure
ma let's do that stopped yeah if you
want a sharp game maybe the the shleimah
nesa is the way to go it's um it's
really aggressive kg5 yeah I've played
this person quite a bit in the
five-minute pool and I never understood
any game he simply place totally
different chests than I play and in most
cases i was thinking I'm just better and
and so on but I lost most games so there
must be something to explain that I
don't don't quite get okay let's see
it's interesting here I have to be seven
porn that a letter attack but the other
side of the body is a different matter I
can take here play night if I have to
get the default square who difficult
difficult 95 immediately can take and
take C Phi if this is not really what I
want I can threaten f3 maybe this is the
idea night back night back to try to
player 3
and f3 is in is a threat okay you can
just move the bishop back somehow it's
questionable if not you won't help me if
he goes Bishop g7 for example ok ok so
we play something drastic the idea is to
take on g3 take on d4 going for tactics
hmm probably ok and then not sure yeah I
don't want to grab stuff there it's not
a good idea ok nighty one wasn't maybe
the most the most testing news can take
with this also I mean Knight takes s
knight c6 ok now he reacted to that if I
I still I cannot take right for then woo
k 7 it's it's interesting but not
decisive not decisive it all look a 5
difficult position ok in this game he's
actually doing something in most other
games where I played him he was just
shuffling around doing nothing and
winning on time this is not such a game
let's see mmm take stinks he has III
actually this is a big problem I didn't
think about the deep on capture for some
reason that it was really badly played
by me yeah I know now it's open the
floodgates him
poor
Jim I'm not getting killed in the next
couple of moves it's not that bad but I
might get killed it might happen 95 is a
huge idea but it's possible that I'm
just falling apart he's really quick
someone mentioned mark captain yeah mark
captain the English grandmaster he's a
very interesting player to watch with
his opening repertoire um he has a
number of nice things that he plays he's
got it he's an e4 e5 specialist and he s
many uh he just goes for G for winning a
piece Wow okay mmm great ah what a
howler jam it's definitely true I really
have to beat this guy sometimes but I
don't I don't somehow it doesn't it
doesn't really work against him I don't
know why okay next game mm okay okay
yeah that's a fun game playing
mandragora this is Grand Master Gao Qi
blonde it's an old friend of mine former
teammate and this is kind of playing I
mean we kind of know each other very
well so let's see what happens not sure
what is going for yeah he's some coming
form I'm going for an head shop here
let's see what he does b3 is what we
looked at years ago but he also might go
lucky one he also had this in his
repertoire
yep b3 that's a very much possible line
the same thing that I play actually III
and 41 mmm d 6 years in the in the
exchange rule up s to play for windows
but black is not easy at all but what
you mostly have to be is very persistent
especially if they want to dry out the
game completely it's difficult to really
do something theory wise i mean there is
no very there's no aggressive option for
black or anything just have to be
patient on move five against castles
night e seven and Bishop e7 are both
interesting but it's pretty much clear
that this is not clearly equalizing I
have played Bishop e7 quite a bit myself
five Bishop e7 oh that's a question
about the the poisoned pawn in the in
the vinner of a French I have no opinion
about that really i have no idea if this
is what this is what the current state
of theory is or whatever i have no idea
that's a question is g6 a viable option
after d4 Knight f6 93 or is there a
smarter way to trick your opponent in
the kit I don't know if this is a trick
or somewhere just normal normal normal
line okay in this game here to talk
about what's actually happening I'm
trying to be active in the center I know
as played f4 um this default move I'm
not sure may be Queen over to be seven
at some point g4 might be a problem okay
it's getting that bear he's putting that
back mmm I was thinking no that's not
going to work take cake or deform hmm
it's not easy to play this position here
and all of this is ready yeah I think
with the poisoned pawn in the French the
vunnava was meant and I really have no
idea about the state there it's um I
mean there's a book currently are just
about to be released or it's released by
um by victor moskalenko they even more
flexible french or something like that
which is probably useful for the french
player to get okay i relocated my knight
to c6 and really thought on this have
net was badly placed and whatever you
can say about this position i actually
was a bit it was a bit quicker than him
which is good um okay Queen to f3 knight
is hanging there I can take c4 but you
can take with the Jeep on
hmm tough miss the night is also hanging
there that can be a problem and f7 is
always kind of weak let's put it back
yeah he made a book on the wind /
exclusively the wonderful whenever I was
just mentioning the book because it is
just about to be released um yeah how do
I get something here g5 is coming here
and we put this back yep my queen is
unprotected that's really a problem
maybe I should protect it to allow to
allow capturing on c4 or something like
that and at least I was quicker
yeah someone is mentioning Nakamura's
openings are not and not something to
copy or something well it's a it's it
depends i mean what nakamura plays in
bliss chairs and in tournament chairs
are two entirely different things really
totally um in blit see very often
actually plays some unsound stuff but
because he just wants to have stuff that
is kind of interesting unexplored he
just wants to wants to once a game and
it's not carrying much if this is really
good or not and in tournament chess he
sometimes gets some gets a bit too
experimental I think yeah sometimes but
not not often nowadays so he really is
has has been he's much more solid than
in comparison to earlier times speaking
about solid I actually sacrificed the
exchange in this game before is
interesting yeah that's a good move
probably he wants to activate his bishop
mmm the default porn is really important
in my position what about can I protect
this the outside screen move that double
attacks that's very irritating I don't
really see a good news in general are
looking at the very top players for
opening a for opening ideas I mean it's
something you can do they rarely play
something that's really bad I mean
almost never but it's not necessarily it
doesn't mean that what the top guys play
is necessarily good for you so it's
really more important to look at what
you are capable of playing and what kind
of position um you you excel in and
quite often this is not the same thing
as what the super the top players play
yeah Luke t5 looks like a self-penned
quite a bit but I don't really see what
else to do okay this one I thought I can
take a five year for let's do this I
think about it longer it wouldn't help
yeah for Luke take c5 and I've 93 and
night h4 wow this is a big pin a big
Fork but i love all get come on right
edge for mmm that was lucky i was lucky
yeah i was probably busted in that game
really busted what I've been lucky
sometimes in this in this session okay
let's have a look there I couldn't
really address all them all the
questions and things mmm yeah I was a
very big Fork yeah he didn't have much
time okay um
let's have a let's have a look there is
there any question hmm the g3 mainline
does suck in the dutch i'm not sure the
dutch defense really is something that
has caught up on the top level both the
stone wall and stone wall and the
leningrad seemed quite okay at the mode
and if you I mean it's interesting it's
um it's interesting to play ok actually
I've occurred any prediction on who will
qualify for the candidates out of the
Grand Prix this month I'm not totally
totally sure who will qualify and simply
because I don't know who's in contention
I think I know that Nakamura is one of
the guys but I'm not sure about the
situation for the other players so on so
I don't turn i dunno i don't really know
the next event that i will make videos
for um it's not so easy to say um the
next big event is Norway chest the
really big event and I won't want to
cover that but when Norway chess is
running I'm on vacation and if I have
the technical equipment I might do it I
might do it dumb from my vacation spot
the difference between the perk and the
modern is that in the perk you have
Knight f6 played all the time and in the
modern you don't so there's the modern
my transpose into the plug if you play
Knight f6 but the perk never transposes
to the modern the modern has the night
back on g8 sometimes to e7 and things
things like that okay um are there any
where when someone someone mentioned
naka Nakamura was quite impressive in
the US Championships I think he was I
actually he he always said that he
wasn't satisfied with his games but that
shows that that
that he's already on a very high level
and wants to really am yeah BM he wants
to improve even beyond that so it's not
satisfied with what he is playing this
question my least favorite chess player
based on opening style of pest
personality yeah my old my name is the
sea on the ISS see i have to mention mr.
vegas i really i doubt that we ever will
become a big friends in a way yeah yeah
for the top players actually think that
from what you what you see what you see
em from the top guys you know in
interviews and so on um we cannot say
that someone dares making a very
unfriendly or bad impression very much I
have to say that I really really
despised what happened in 2006 and
Alicia in this match between two part of
and chrome Nagant what to Pylos kemper
did there was totally unacceptable
however to palo firm when he when you
see him in his interviews and when he is
some how is some how is some kind of
acting when he's analyzing games or Sony
makes a very nice friendly impression so
it's kind of weird that that his cam was
was acting like it did in this match its
kind of kind of strange yeah someone
suggest i should get messy technical
positions against mr. what I guess
that's true i would like to but somehow
he has this uncanny ability to trade off
everything yet and i have a hard time to
avoid that okay we already passed the
one hour mark i will do one final game
in the three-minute pool with some some
funky stuff how can we get an aggressive
position here against this person who is
this actually volta are in shibuya
Rodriguez so we have
french and maybe get some sharp position
down let's see what this guy I don't
know what is what he is playing them one
more one more game yeah I think happy
should be seven I don't know ok let's
take but i'm really i have no idea here
how this is played
I know if I castle long this is this can
be kind of tricky with b5 happening
quickly so I'm playing over the secret
special a six but okay that's not the
end of the world not sure I should have
made me play Bishop e2 it it's no big
problem
yeah someone someone is mentioning they
have have the question about players
that seem seem I don't know friendly our
players that you like I don't like I
really think that I mean you really
don't know the guys yeah you only can
get a pretty superficial impression and
based on that I cannot really tell that
someone is I don't know nicer than the
other guy or something I don't know I
really don't don't thank you you get I
can get a clear picture there ok I'm
going a 3 I don't want to give up their
porn at some point I rooks afore yes oh
he doesn't he plays it in a very simple
fashion here so it's not very exciting I
tried with e4 but it didn't it didn't
really happen
try to gain a bit of space there yeah
it's still it's nothing much maybe
g-form ultimately try to open up the
King side and push h5 I mean bishop
endgame I might be able to press a
little bit it's nothing serious of
course but I can try for h5 I mean you
might play before ok h5 takes takes
takes and he SC 3 hmm that's really
nothing at all ah that's less than
anything actually hmm how do I play here
this is three minute that's important I
have to speed up here absolutely ok yeah
he s this deformed hmm i played this
badly actually he has deformed this is
the big issue that's really really bad
and not necessary at all I really had a
nice position I mean nothing great but
nothing that should should loose like it
just like it happens now I don't have
bishop I don't I didn't have Bishop d3
again I don't have this move because of
rugby three
yeah I have no move him can also Kenned
really just take no he doesn't
Jim okay that wasn't a really great
technical play um I can take here well
this is a draw but I have 30 seconds
that's not easy oops no no I wanted to
go to you three okay so i can safely
resign that one okay nothing to do here
okay um okay what do we have here any
any other things Oh someone is cursing
in the chat that's not nice he that's
it's really i come to come into to to
come into a chess chess broadcast and
funny yeah okay guys I hope you enjoyed
it there was some some interesting games
I think and I'm glad I did quite well
with my new mouse it's it's really a
difficult thing to change the change the
playing gear okay hope you liked it
thanks for watching till next week bye
guys